hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter 15 of epic uses discourses
contains a really interesting topic of
discussion which allows us to
distinguish between what is actually
taught by the stoic philosophy and what
might appear to be taught by it but it
is very clearly not taught by it in his
contrary to the stoic way of approaching
things and this is the attitude or the
problem only white snake
stubbornness or or hardness you know
when we talk about somebody having a
heart or hurt and not wanting to listen
to other people once they've made up
their mind off students he is another
way of translating this by the way this
is one of the passages in which the word
sophomore gets used
Epictetus says you know I don't really
want to have friends for wise fools in
this way and that's what sophomore means
there's sort of a paradox Akala t to it
so he's saying some people actually get
stoic doctrines wrong
he says when they heard the following
precepts one want to be steadfast good
right that's true and the moral purpose
is naturally free and not subject of
compulsion also true and good well
everything else is liable
and compulsion subject to others not our
own also good good starting points right
if he says well some people then I fancy
that whenever they formed a judgment
they ought to stand by it
immovable right so once they've made a
judgment about something they should
stick with it
stubbornly now allow themselves to be
moved and the question is well does that
actually they're convinced that that's
what they want to do nobody else can
change my mind I've got total freedom
over screw everybody else screw the
world I'm going to think what I like
nobody's going to convince me otherwise
because I have that choice now it's
clear that they can in fact do that
because a lot of people do do precisely
that
quite often that it comes out when they
have a discussion with somebody and you
know they try to have some dialogue and
then they just take their stand and
they're not going to be moved from it
but the real question is well should
they be doing them Epictetus says think
about this what's what's being left out
here is it important just to take a
position and then stick with it and we
might say the same thing from Oh
critical thinking perspective is it
important is the most important thing
that you articulate your point of view
and then you provide all sorts of
arguments for it or is it more important
that you actually make sure that your
point of view
isn't crazy that it's actually in touch
with reality that it's reflective of
some sort of evidence it's not enough
just to be able to argue your case or to
take a stand and say Here I am I shall
not be moved from this it's important
that it be the right stand because if
it's not you're actually doing something
point that you're you're harming
yourself and you're probably harming
others in the process so it's much more
important to focus on getting your
judgments right in the first place and
this is what
really problematic about this attitude
of stubbornness not only he hasn't left
that out of the picture but by taking
the sort of attitude that it is by
hardening the position it makes it
difficult to impossible to actually
bring this to the person's attention so
epictetus gives some examples here he
says you know here here's here's what
happened I had a friend of mine for no
reason
made up his mind to starve himself to
death I learned about it when he was
already in the third Davis fasting and
went and asked what had he happened I
have decided the answer of an epic
cynicism that's fine
but what was it that induced you to make
up your mind for if your judgment was
good see we are at your side and ready
to help you make your exit from this
life but if your judgment was irrational
change it and then the guy says I have
to abide by my decisions now see at this
point you can see that there's something
wrong
Epictetus has asked him I think that
what you're doing might have to be
called into question what was your
reasoning leading to this why didn't you
do it I mean if you're doing the right
thing
I've got your back I'm totally behind
you just want to know why you're doing
this and the guy says I made the choice
now is that is that an actual response
that really it's it's a closing things
off rather than responding so epictetus
says very well but still what was it
that induced you to make up your mind if
you judgment was good you know he says
what are you doing you mean not all your
decisions but over the right ones the
guy says I need to I need to stick by my
decisions right why that's a global
judgment right I have to stick by all of
my judgments how do you know that
judgments correct have you tested it
have you analyzed it have you happening
they say a fresh pair of eyes on it
Epictetus says you don't mean all your
decisions only the right ones for
example as you're convinced at this
moment it's night don't change your
opinion if that seems best to you but
abide by it and say that you ought to
abide by your decisions do you not wish
to make your beginning and foundation
firm that is to consider whether your
decision is sound or unsound and only
after you've done that proceed to you
know it's a build upon the structure of
your determination and your firm resolve
if you have arrived in front of a
crumbling foundation you can't build
even a small building but the bigger and
the stronger your superstructure is the
more quickly it's going to fall down
without any reason you're taking out of
this life to our detriment a human being
who is a familiar friend a citizen of
the same state with the large state of
the small and then though in the act of
murder and while engaged in the
destruction of human being has done no
wrong you say you must abide by your
decisions but if the idea ever entered
in your hand killed me would you have to
abide by your decisions so this is a
very important point he's saying this is
a big thing right here why are you just
you know stubbornly sticking to a
decision that you made when you don't
actually know whether it's the right
decision
look I'm giving you some new
considerations here think about what
you're doing and everybody who cares
about you think about what you're doing
to your society think about the fact
that you're not supposed to be doing
this and the guy just wants to stick
with it no epic scene of sense some
people you cannot reach you can't get
them to actually change their views this
actually goes against what is good for
them he says it's to her advantage to be
persuaded that it's not enough to him
reach decisions and to refuse to change
that condition of stubbornness is not
good for us it's to our advantage to
listen and say all right let me see if I
can provide you with some sort of
justification for
da if we're unwilling to do that he says
this is really a kind of madness an
illness or sickness of the mind being
irrational being irrational about what
is most important to us and it has to be
treated accordingly he also says that
people like that are not to be reliable
you might think that they are going to
stick completely with whatever it is
that they've decided but the problem is
since the only basis for them sticking
with their judgment their decision is
the fact that they say that's important
to me what if that changes what if the
next moment they say well I'm going to
decide this instead what are they really
getting making this claim that they are
somehow being steadfast when really
they're only being stubborn that's an
important thing that one would have to
analyze and so Epictetus you know he
goes with how many says some some very
important things about this he says rest
assured there's nothing to prevent you
from someday turning irrationally to the
opposite decision I have decided is not
an actual reason to stick with things he
says this is the way the sick mind goes
it's uncertain which way is inclined but
when vehement was added to this then the
evil gets past help and past cure it
gets stuck into the person and they're
you know not going to change the way
that they're there orienting themselves
he gives another example earlier on
about the body says I want vigor in the
body but it must be the vigor of the
body and stated health and physical
exercise where if you show me that you
possess the figure of a man man boast
about it I will say to you look for
someone to cure you this is not vigor
but actually weakness or or feebleness
this is not the state of mind that a
person who
is doing stomach philosophy in a
practical way is going to fall into this
is something that sometimes does get
portrayed as stoicism because a person
is is being resolute they're taking a
position they are using the freedom of
their faculty of choice to do that
they're saying I'm not going to let
external things like threats or other
people's you know attempts to provide me
with incentives or anything like that
change my mind I'm not going to succumb
to social pressure but it's actually
something very different from the
attitude of stomach because the stomach
is like a Senate concerned with getting
the judgments right in the first place
and then building upon those that's not
to say that you know if you're a stoic
you have to somehow be you know throwing
everything up in the air all the time
the stoic is a is a dogmatic position in
that there are dog monta that is you
know sort of teachings that they think
are correct and they're gonna keep
following but you know the stoic is the
first person to say that you know you
know if the dog mama turned out to be
wrong then you need to move away from
them before you actually judge that
they're wrong though you want to make
sure that that judgment is actually
correct as well you don't want to be
over hasty in doing that but it's not
going to be anything like this obstinacy
that's that's irrational and that's not
fulfilling the purpose of a human being
which is to develop a Faculty of choice
that is free unrestrained that can
orient oneself and then move into the
good the good for human beings